l'uomo da un discorso un po controverso
quello che lari summers
l'ex presidente di harvard fece nel 2005
per spiegare perché le donne nella
scienza faticano diciamo a progredire
nella carriera è bene lui disse che c è
dovuta delle differenze innate tra
uomini e donne differenze nelle abilità
matematiche logico computazionali
tuttavia aggiunse summer queste
differenze sono rafforzate da due
fattori da una parte la socializzazione
e dall'altra le discriminazioni
ovviamente discorso di summers fece
molto scalpore qualche anno dopo lo
scrittore ian mcewan s'ispirò lui al
personaggio per costruire un grottesco
personaggio in uno dei suoi libri solar
però destroso di summers è molto utile
per affrontare il tema del pregiudizio
perché pone l'accento su tre fattore
importante
ricordiamoci di bene differenza innata e
socializzazione discriminazione sono
queste tre ipotesi su cui le scienze
sociali hanno lungamente lo stanno
ancora facendo indagato lo stanno ancora
facendo per poter spiegare le
disuguaglianze di genere nel mondo del
lavoro nella scienza
insomma al punto di summers era che le
donne nella scienza sono meno bravi
degli uomini è un pregiudizio
assolutamente sì ma per capire che cos'è
un pregiudizio bisogna fare un passo
indietro la parola pregiudizio significa
giudizio prematuro
il passo indietro è quello di riflettere
su un concetto importante che è quello
dello schema i pregiudizi nascono dagli
schemi che cos'è lo schema lo schema è
una mappa mentale un framework cognitivo
che ci consente di catalogare esempi
specifici in categorie più ampio e vi
faccio un esempio quando mi hanno messo
questo microfono qualche minuto fa io
questo specifico microfono non l'avevo
mai visto prima non avevo mai incontrato
eppure lo schema di che cos'è un
microfono contiene alcune informazioni
per esempio di che materiale dovrebbe
essere costruito che forma dovrebbe
avere
e che mi hanno suggerito che questo e un
microfono a mi hanno consentito di
riconoscerlo
ecco gli schemi quindi sono ciò che ci
consentono di riconoscere ciò che ci
circonda e quindi di navigare il mondo
sono assolutamente essenziali quindi
primo step lo schema lo schema funziona
un po come un pop up no una nuvola
dovete pensare a un po come uno al cloud
in questo cloud ci sono tante
informazioni tra queste informazioni ci
sono gli stereotipi quindi secondo step
stereotipo cos'è uno stereotipo lo
sterotipo è un attributo una
caratteristica una qualità insomma si
può tradurre in un aggettivo vi faccio
un esempio io vado in montagna vedo
qualcosa che assomiglia a una vipera no
lo schema il mio schema di vip e
racconti in alcune informazioni no per
esempio è grigio marrone corta ed è
velenosa e queste informazioni mi
inducono a pensare che sia una vipera ma
magari un innocuo serpente magari ho
fatto un errore quindi schema stereotipo
esiste una parola molto bella che va
anche di moda adesso no in inglese che
sostituisce la parola stereotipo in
italiano ed è by us by al significa
distorsione perché lo stereotipo è
un'informazione distorta e il
pregiudizio è il bayern agito il
pregiudizio e la valutazione che si basa
sullo stereotipo quindi se lo stereotipo
è un'informazione distorta il
pregiudizio è una valutazione distorta
ma distorta rispetto a cosa
per rispetto alla valutazione corretta
corretta sulla base di un informazione
elaborata raccogliendola dalla realtà
dall oggetto di valutazione e non dalla
mia testa
se l'informazione nasce dall union tale
potrebbe essere errata schema byas
pregiudizio questa triade il problema è
che non si applica solo ai microfoni
alle vipere e ottica anche alle persone
quando interagiamo con loro o peggio
quando magari dobbiamo valutarle per un
colloquio di lavoro o per affidare loro
un progetto dai tanti schemi che
utilizziamo per valutare le persone ci
sono quelli basati su gruppi sociali di
appartenenti ai gruppi sociali a cui
appartengono queste persone
infatti si parla di schema di genere
schema sociale etnico sessuale
generazionale eccetera piccolo piccolo
esempio piccolo gioco
se dico la parola donna che cosa vi
viene in mente
bisogna essere veloci perché i
pregiudizi funzionano sulla velocità io
quando faccio questa domanda al di
studenti in aula in azienda insomma le
risposte più ricorrenti sono dolcezza
gentilezza bellezza cura sapersi
prendere cura sapersi ascoltare e saper
riconoscere le proprie emozioni che però
fa il paio con emotività che fa il paio
con tendenza a prendere delle decisioni
su base irrazionali e quindi scarsa
capacità di leadership
se vi dico la parola uomo che cosa vi
viene in mente mi risponderete forza
virage ha senso della protezione magari
manualità pensiero logico strumentale
calma ma anche aggressività quando serve
quindi autorevolezza scarsa capacità di
ascoltarsi e ascoltare quanti schemi
quante quante gabbie in cui noi mettiamo
le persone
credete che questi schemi non
influiscano nell'interazione che noi
abbiamo con quelle persone credete che
non influiscano sulle scelte delle
persone e quindi sul mondo del lavoro
adesso faccio un salto logico ma
facciamo due più due per essere un buon
ingegnere devi avere capacità logico
strumentali per essere un buon top
manager devi avere capacità di
leadership
ecco queste caratteristiche noi la
società tendiamo con maggiore
probabilità a ricondurre agli uomini
piuttosto che alle donne e quindi noi
tenderemo a pensare che gli uomini siano
fatti naturalmente per quelle
professioni per quelle posizioni e
quando vedremo una donna che occupa
quegli spazi e bene la forse la vedremo
con un po di diffidenza o la
giudicheremo più se veramente esiste
esiste una letteratura molto vasta sui
byas di genere nel mercato del lavoro e
nella scienza e gran parte una buona
fetta di studi si basa sul metodo
sperimentale io adesso non non starò di
entrare nei dettagli metodologici basti
sapere che si tratta di simulare oa
volte di inserirsi in processi di
reclutamento del personale sottoponendo
a degli intervistati dei possibili
reclutatori o inviando delle aziende
delle coppie di civili candidati coppie
di cibi di candidati che si equivalgono
nel percorso scolastico nei titolo di
studio negli anni di esperienza nelle
competenze nelle skills sono candidati
con un equivalente uguali
caratteristiche eccetto per una il
genere perché per misurare se esiste la
discriminazione dobbiamo paragonare
uomini e donne con caratteristiche
uguali
la conclusione a cui arriva a cui
arrivano questi studi è molto semplice
cioè se noi dovessimo inviare 2cv
equivalenti di nuovo di una donna ad
un'azienda bere la donna avrà meno
probabilità di essere assunta rispetto
all'uomo
altri studi dimostrano che questo è vero
anche per la promozione e per l'aumento
di stipendio e ciò ancora più vero per
quelle professioni ed occupazioni che
sono tradizionalmente maschili come per
esempio le stelle uno studio di ieri
2012 dimostra che il reclutatore in quel
caso dei biologi di prestigiose
università americane tendono a dare un
punteggio alle candidate donne inferiore
rispetto ai candidati uomini con le
stesse caratteristiche ea dare loro a
decidere per loro uno stipendio di
partenza più basso
questo era per una posizione di lab
manager manager di laboratorio
esistono tantissimi studi che vanno in
questa direzione ma secondo l esempio
più efficace viene dalla musica
all'inizio degli anni settanta alle
donne rappresentavano il 5 per cento dei
componenti delle orchestre negli stati
uniti tra gli anni settanta e ottanta le
orchestre americane e ne ho iniziato a
introdurre la blind e udc
l'audizione ceca che oggi si usa in
tutte le orche esse c'è tra il candidato
la candidata che aspira ad entrare in
un'orchestra e la commissione di
valutazione c'è una tenda nera
ebbene l'economista claudia goldin alla
fine degli anni 90 ha calcolato
analizzando appunto i processi di
selezione delle orchestre americane che
la blind audi shaun la tenda nera
aumentato la probabilità delle donne di
essere assunto in un'orchestra americana
del 50 per cento
che cosa significa che cosa suggerisce
questo studio è bene che forse i
valutatori prima dell'introduzione della
tenda nera non prendevano la loro
decisione basandosi esclusivamente su
un'informazione corretta che in quel
caso era la performance musicale del
candidato ma probabilmente erano
influenzati dai byas di schemi byas di
genere che includono le stereotipo
secondo cui le donne non sono così brave
come gli uomini a suonare bene ma da
dove arrivano questi stereotipi perché
gli stereotipi come dire a un certo
punto si creano i bambini non ce li
hanno
ecco un contributo importante a questa
per rispondere a questa domanda lo danno
gli studi sui test di matematica
esistono molti studi su di di studi le
metanalisi che di fatto ci dicono che
non esistono differenze nelle capacità
matematiche logico computazionali di
bambine e bambini
quantomeno fino a un'età che si aggira
attorno ai 12 13 anni dopo quell'età i
ragazzi iniziano a sovraperformare
leggermente le ragazze matematiche le
ragazze a sovraperformare leggermente i
ragazzi nella comprensione dei test mi
riferisco per esempio i test pisa
inoltre questo gap nell'adolescenza è di
gran lunga inferiore rispetto a quello
che era tanti anni fa quindi c'è un
miglioramento nel tempo cambia da paese
a paese ci sono paesi in cui le ragazze
sono più brave dei ragazzi e soprattutto
questo gap si
come dire capovolge all'università le
ragazze nelle facoltà scientifiche
performano meglio dei ragazzi ma questo
perché per di un processo di selezione
cioè loro sono dovute passare attraverso
una selezione dura
ovvero combattere contro le aspettative
di genere che non le considerano
competenti in quelle materie quindi sono
mediamente in media più motivate e più
performanti con buona pace di larry
summers mi verrebbe da dire ma
ritorniamo alla variabilità del dato non
il gap si crea una certa età in
adolescenza varia da paese a paese nel
tempo che cosa significa significa una
cosa sola che le differenze nelle
performance matematiche non sono innate
non sono innate ma dipendono dai fattori
socio culturali dal contesto e c'è anche
un'altra un'altra domanda però che
legittima che è la seguente però un
certo punto si formano no abbiamo detto
non esistono da bambino ad un certo
punto si formano per car che le ragazze
iniziano a perdere fiducia in se stesse
e iniziano a perdere fiducia in se
stesse perché ragazze e ragazzi vivono
in un contesto in cui ricevono spesso
anche in con inconsapevolmente e anche
da insegnanti e genitori dei feedback di
approvazione o meno diversi rispetto
alle loro competenze quindi le ragazze a
furia di sentirsi dire o di percepirlo
no nello sguardo nella valutazione degli
altri che non sono bravi matematica
finiranno per non esserlo chiudiamo il
cerchio
i tre fattori alla base delle
disuguaglianze evocati da summers
differenze innate socializzazione
discriminazione e bene le argomentazioni
i nazisti hanno perso terreno nel
dibattito scientifico le differenze
nelle performance matematiche si creano
per via dei processi di socializzazione
noi nasciamo e cresciamo in un contesto
dove respiriamo assorbiamo e
riproduciamo aspettative di genere e
queste aspettative di genere ci
suggeriscono anche come comportarci e
che cosa desiderare
ecco anche la questione delle preferenze
no le ragazze preferiscono iscriversi a
lettere ragazzi a fisica e bene dobbiamo
avere uno sguardo critico e fare un
passo indietro le preferenze non cadono
dal cielo non piovono dal per uranio
sono sempre contestualizzate io non sto
dicendo che non ci sia spazio di azione
noi sociologia
parla dell'inter relazione tra il
soggetto che agisce che desidera che
sceglie e il contesto fatto di
opportunità che sono diverse per uomini
e per donne le preferenze appunto
[Musica]
passiamo appunto dalla dalla dal mondo
delle ragazze al mondo delle donne le
preferenze addirittura non solo nascono
in un contesto ma si modificano a
seconda degli ostacoli che si incontrano
appunto il mondo delle aziende si dice
che le donne non chiedono chiedono meno
degli uomini un aumento di stipendio
sanno negoziare me in una promozione ma
voi pensate davvero che le donne
vogliono guadagnare meno degli uomini
se io so perché lui me lo dicono i dati
perché vedo come funziona la mia azienda
che le donne progrediscono meno nella
carriera se io so che quando chiederò
una promozione il mio responsabile
reagirà o con stupore o forse con
migrando con una reazione negativa bene
ci penserà due volte prima di andare a
chiedere una promozione non lo farò e
quindi andrò a confermare il pregiudizio
che le donne non sanno chiedere non
sanno negoziare una produzione un
aumento di stipendio però questa si
chiama in realtà rimodulazione delle
aspettative o rimodulazione delle
preferenze delle aspirazioni e le
aspettative si rimodulano perché i costi
che le donne pagano per raggiungere gli
stessi obiettivi sono più elevati per
loro e sono più elevati non solo per gli
stereotipi individuali del datore di
lavoro la cosiddetta discriminazione
diretta ma lo sono anche per tutti quei
meccanismi spesso invisibili cui non
abbiamo molto il tempo di parlare oggi
che sussistono persistono essere
producono all'interno delle
organizzazioni nella loro cultura nella
loro struttura
la rimodulazione delle preferenze è un
concetto molto importante perché ci dice
una cosa interessante che gli stereotipi
sono profezie che si auto avverano
gli stereotipi sono interiorizzati
riprodotti da chi li subisce
per poter con piacere lo sguardo degli
altri e quindi andando a confermare il
pregiudizio negli occhi di chi guarda
quindi è un po serpente che si morde la
coda
ma che noi possiamo un meccanismo che
comunque noi possiamo fermare come con
quelle che io chiamo amo chiamare le
lenti del gender le lenti del genere e
sono delle lenti che ti consentono di
vedere tutti questi meccanismi spesso
invisibili alla base delle
disuguaglianze di opportunità e ti
consentono di vedere gli schemi di
genere perché il primo passo per poter
liberarsi degli schemi di genere che
sono gabbie di genere e la
consapevolezza e gli schemi di genere e
fanno male non solo alle donne ma anche
agli uomini e liberarsene significa
essere liberi di essere di fare ciò che
si vuole essere ciò che si vuole fare
quantomeno il più possibile e se ciò che
corrispondere magari un'idea
tradizionale di femminilità e
mascolinità ben poco male l'importante è
esserne consapevoli consapevoli anche
che esiste un rapporto diciamo di potere
di gerarchia nei ruoli tradizionali di
genere
ad ogni modo essere liberi di essere e
di fare perché combattere gli stereotipi
in fondo significa amare la libertà
grazie